i moved to new york alone at 15 to
create my first company and have been
alone here since then you know my
family's back in sydney and i dropped
out of
you know middle school so i kind of
sacrificed everything and like the
kind of brutal way to put it is that if
you don't sacrifice everything you know
the goal becomes the sacrifice
and i've consistently found that you
know just being really hyper focused on
one thing
is how you make that one thing come
alive
[Music]
my name is ben pastanak and i'm the
founder and ceo of simulate
my company is a nutrition technology
company and we make a product called
nuggs which is a chicken nugget
simulation the reason we founded the
company
was we felt that food has been kind of
rejecting
technology as an industry and if you
look at other industries like say
transportation you know we've
essentially gone from horseback to
you know multi-planetary rockets in a
couple hundred years
and we still produce the same you know
food the same way
so we think that redefining how humans
get their nutrition
represents one of the greatest
opportunities to improve how people live
[Music]
i think the american dream you know is
like giving half a million dollars to a
15 year old to work on whatever
whatever they want and i you know i was
given that opportunity
and it's something i appreciate every
single day i kind of say that every idea
is a bad idea
and certainly ours was you know we
launched as just ddc chicken nuggets
which
truly sounds like a really bad idea it
just takes a lot of force to like bring
something to life and now we you know
never get questioned on what we're doing
[Music]
it's kind of cliche but you know you
have to stay hyper focused and you have
to be
super persistent it's it's at the start
it's just so brutal it really feels like
everyone against you
and you you have to keep pushing and as
long as you stay focused you
you don't get sucked into any
distractions you'll succeed it's
actually it's a pretty simple formula
that people oversee
but all you have to do is be persistent
stay focused and eventually you'll
figure it out
you